hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about languages
[Music]
uh today i would like to talk about a
subject that has come up it came up in
my discussion with jeremy
about korea
and it's a subject that comes up all the
time
it is this idea of cultural obstacles
when we learn a language
so
remember now if uh by the way i finished
my uh 90-day
arabic challenge
probably go back to either persian or
turkish
but if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe if you
click on the bell you get notifications
and by all means come and join me at
link to learn languages
so
you know someone once said that when we
learn a language
uh we are imitating
an element or a part of the culture
we're imitating parts of another culture
because the language is part of
french japanese chinese russian whatever
it might be it's part of that culture
part of english speaking culture it's
part of their culture we we're trying to
imitate it we're trying to penetrate
that world
and
as a person who is not a native speaker
of any of those languages or any
language
we are an outsider
so it is obvious that we're an outsider
until we are extremely fluent in the
language and even then people will
identify us in many cases as as a
foreigner we're not part of the in-group
or sort of the out-group
and so it's all it's difficult to be an
outsider and and it's natural for the
in-group to kind of resist
the outsider with the funny accent and
has trouble saying
things and is not familiar with their
culture
and and so it's a bit of a foreign
object it's not quite
something in your eye but it can disturb
now conversely there could be people who
are particularly interested in you
because you are different and so you
bring an element in that they don't have
within their in group but most the time
you're an outsider trying to get in
i always feel that the onus is on the
outsider to try to get in
and not to worry about whether you're
accepted whether they like you whether
not to worry about your accent your your
pronunciation not to hang back in your
own culture and feel somehow that maybe
your culture is i may not be able to
speak your language but my language is
better than your language or my culture
is better no to me it's just about i
want to be part of your culture
i'm not coming here with my flag flying
saying i am an english-speaking canadian
and i want to join your group i'm just a
person
and i'm interested in joining your group
i'm interested in learning your language
i'm interested in learning about your
culture
i would like you to accept me but i
understand that i'm
i'm a
foreigner i'm outside the group so i
have to try harder and even if i sense
at times an element of rejection or
resistance or
you know
less than the welcome that i i would
like to have i have to still continue
because
in amongst all those members within that
in-group in any society it can be in
japan in france
you know
foreigners in the united states or
canada or whatever
there will be those people who will
accept you for what you are
and there will be those people who don't
and that's true everywhere and it's true
in terms of your own culture
in in the way that members of your
culture accept outsiders who want to
come into your cultural space and so
when you go to
enter into
someone else's cultural space you just
have to you know put your head down and
charge forward and don't get easily
ticked off or offended and just keep
going and you will event you'll bounce
off the people who aren't so happy to
have you and you'll find the ones that
are and in doing so you'll gradually
improve your language skills so that
they will increasingly accept you as one
of them so that i just wanted to say
that about about this whole business of
sort of cultural obstacles you have to
overcome them and not everyone is going
to welcome you but many people will
and the better you get in the language
the more welcoming they will be so just
a little note on cultural obstacles
bye for now
[Music]